bye on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening i'm pierce morgan on
sense of this hour the navy seal who
killed osama bin laden royal expert
magazine royalty tina brown and tv's
baddest dad brian cox
but first comedian dave chappelle was
attacked on stage while performing a
netflix gig in los angeles the streaming
giant's biggest comedy star has long
faced protests and even sentenced
sinister threats of violence
but dissecting issues like race and
gender politics in america so with
comedians now fearing for their safety
for going about the business of trying
to make people laugh was the attack on
chappelle also an attack on free speech
he's comedian and wrestling superstar
tyrus and the british stand-up dame
baptiste asked how his incident compares
to will smith slapping chris rock at the
oscars
when will smith did that he being who he
is in the position he is he just said
hey this is what you do when you don't
like what they say because he had no
consequences
he wasn't dragged off by security and
thrown out and embarrassed and
humiliated he literally went back to his
seat and then talked more trash
so when when people see this especially
the lower end of our society and they
thinking how can i that guy didn't go to
the comedy show and he wasn't sitting
there going and he heard a joke that he
was so offended that he jumped up and he
went there premeditated he had a weapon
he was there because two things were
going to happen one he was going to get
a lot of attention he was going to be on
the news and he'd be able to say
whatever political thing he wanted to
say and how comedy is this and that the
only thing he didn't count on was that
dave chappelle works out he's shredded
like a julian salad he hangs out with
busta rhymes who's like a biscuit away
from 300 pounds and he's got a really
serious security team as snoop's former
bodyguard i had a very same similar
situation and i left the guy just as
twisted so he got some real life
consequences so hopefully all the woke
that see that we can make a statement by
going after comedians uh they'll think
twice because this is what happens in
the real world well you know what
tyler's side of that is i'll say you've
actually you've actually made me think
twice on what you just said
uh you've made me rethink what i think
about the will smith chris rock thing
because i was a little bit not defensive
of will smith but i was understanding
but in terms of the precedent that it
set i think you make a very good point
that guy may well have been inspired by
what's happened at the oscars and that
may well now be parroted across america
and other countries we bring in uh dane
baptiste dame
you're a stand-up comedian you perform
in front of audience all the time they
can get raucous they can get noisy you
can get hecklers but when you see
somebody of dave chappelle's statue i
think he's one of the great comedians in
the world today if not of all time
you see someone like him attacked by
somebody with a replica gun which had a
spring-up knife in it and literally
could have killed it
what did that what made you
think about that what's your view about
that what happens now next time you go
out in front of an audience um i mean
whatever happens to me will remain
exactly the same peers if someone
crosses the boundary of approaching me
on stage it no longer is the paradigm of
a comedian and audience what you're
dealing with then is a potential
belligerent or assailant and me as a
civilian having the right to defend
myself
with that being said i am not somebody
who uh is adverse to the plight of the
trans community or the transgender
community but at the same time i think
anyone who has taken the time to build
context of dave chappelle on his
narrative would understand that he has
made it a point of principle uh artistic
principle to hold america and the
western civilization under a microscope
and examine various groups and i think
he does that from the position of fool
and so it's very worrying that people
will resort to violence especially uh
with deadly weapons and again uh i am
pain to but i do agree with yourself and
tyrus in terms of the fact that this may
be a present that's been set by will
smith's actions which has encouraged
people to believe that they are able to
use physical force in order to quote a
narrative they don't necessarily agree
with and um i think it's probably the
most extreme and potentially most lethal
form of censorship that exists in our
society with that being said i want to
thank you for unblocking me on twitter
as well yeah and uh
it was kind of funny actually i'm doing
a show called piers morgan on censored
and dame before he came on pointed out
to our producers i blocked him on
twitter so i had to uncancel you dane
which is what we do on this show exactly
formally on cancel we're back in twitter
love to with each other let me bring
taurus back in taurus
we've seen some weird stuff going on
this we saw the chris rock thing we saw
uh this thing last night with dave
chappelle we also saw you know random
strangers on planes baiting mike tyson i
think it happened again yesterday with
somebody else with mike tyson
what is going on here are people just
going slightly mad because of a pandemic
because of other issues do you feel
there's a rising tension amongst the
populace or am i overthinking it
no unfortunate you're not overthinking
it but you're
you're giving them too much credit this
comes down to
fame seeking attention seeking and
whatever message they want to get out
it's just like here's the thing with the
thing with dave chappelle real quickly
groups are coming out saying this is
what happens when you use words that
hurt people's feelings so it was dave
chappelle's fault it was like basically
saying how were you dressed when he
attacked you instead of owning the fact
that there is never a good reason if
someone says something you don't like
you never get it there's no reason to
put hands on him you just don't watch
him anymore the thing with mike tyson is
the guy who got into it mike tyson got
spread he goes all over the his twitter
is up he's getting all kinds of
attention so you know they're see
they're targeting celebrities especially
um
looks like they're targeting black
celebrities like brothers we getting
targeted because anything we do to them
they end up being the victim
yeah but dane um in terms of comedy
itself is there a line you know people
say to me well here's morgan uncensored
is there a line you won't cross on the
show other things guests could say are
there jokes they could tell which will
cross a line i think there is a line i
don't think anything is acceptable you
incite you know death threats against
people if you incite violence against
people i think that crosses the line but
as a comedian you know you reference
their dave chappelle's material about
the trans community i don't think he
does it from a place of hate at all i
don't think he's transphobic i think
he's talking about issues that have been
raised very publicly in the trans world
which i think should be openly debated
but you know are you suggesting that in
some way when you say that that there
are things that are off limits in terms
of topics rather than direct threats of
violence
um i don't think there should be any
topic that's necessarily off the table
for a comedian but i think it's
important for people to remember that as
a comedian you are taking a position
arguably overfall so to speak and so um
and as an artist your work is always
dynamic so even if dave chappelle does
make a statement that does appear to be
incendiary towards a particular minority
group that doesn't necessarily mean that
he's condemning them or he's ratifying
any violence or marginalization of said
group he is always open to be able to go
back and revisit his material with the
more uh knowledge and information he
receives from that particular group but
i think the problem is is that we are
now living in a time where um the
bipartisan political spectrum has failed
us and we're not able to find ideologues
and politicians that we can necessarily
trust there's a lot of duplicity amongst
that so people look to other uh uh
people with platforms and unfortunately
as a result of which because comedians
and comedy as an art form does tend to
feature as an honest form of politics it
means that we are now being singled out
as focal points for anybody's kind of
angst right issues uh taurus i don't let
you go without giving you a plug for
your book which is roaring up the charts
on amazon i saw your tweet today
congratulations on that very quickly
what's the title of the book and what's
it about
uh the name of the book is just tyrus uh
a memoir and it's just basically about
uh all the jobs i've had been fired from
so it's a lot of stories of how you take
failure and uh you turn it into
something else and how you transition
from one to the other and um you know
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
well it's uh it's storming the charts i
can't wait to read it great to have you
on the show thank you very much taurus
always a pleasure sir it's an honor and
i want to be back the honor is mine uh
and thank you also today
thank you for having me pierce
war heroes don't get much bigger than
this in the week that marks the
anniversary of osama bin laden's death
the man who killed him former navy seal
rob o'neal and as the grim war in
ukraine rages on i asked him what he
would do about the butcher vladimir
putin
i don't think we could take out uh
vladimir putin the way we did osama bin
laden simply because he's the head of
state he's got a lot more defense he's
got lines of security around him you're
not just going to be able to sneak in
there under the radar like we did with
bin laden and i don't think it'd be
worth our our interest in potentially
starting a nuclear war the way to get to
him is to go behind the scenes and i
know we have men and women in the
intelligence service that are looking
for a coup looking for some sort of
assassination attempt but unfortunately
we here in the united states have
sitting senators who like to get on
television and say that out loud because
they're not really worried about
getting rid of putin they're worried
about ratings for themselves so that
they can get uh campaign funding so they
can get whatever politician wants
another uh term and that's it but i
think the way uh is through a coup and i
think they have something like that plan
coming up hopefully
when you look at what's happening in
ukraine as a military man
i mean you must be sick aren't you of
seeing these scenes play out on real
time on social media now which we didn't
obviously have in previous wars where
you see maternity hospitals being bombed
you see holocaust survivors being shot
dead in their homes you see refugees
being targeted as they try and flee with
their with their children what do you
think of it rob and how frustrated does
it make you well it's very very
frustrating because a lot of these
people that are taking other countries
to war aren't doing it for the reasons
they say vladimir putin said there was a
nazi uprising in kiev and that's what
he's telling the soldiers who are
massing on the border or they're doing
you know different kinds of drills uh
and they they've you know the ukrainian
people are defending themselves but like
you said they're being executed mass
graves there's death squads going in
there by the direction of vladimir putin
with no uniforms they can kill people
and take the spoils of war even right
now uh may 9th is coming up called
russian it's called victory day where
the russians you know beat the nazis and
they they're going to celebrate it at
mary opal yeah they're having civilians
clean up a theater site where they've
killed hundreds of people in a bombing
the place where it said children inside
they had white flags outside they're
making civilians clear that out now
right just for food so they can eat so
that the russians can have a parade
there and show the russian people back
home look look we're winning look over
here yeah i mean it it makes your
stomach churn the the difference like
the difference in him and hitler is is
one thing putin is armed with a nuclear
arsenal of 6 000 nuclear weapons and
he's now starting to use that in a very
threatening way to prevent people
getting engaged with him which is not
supposed to be the point of a nuclear
deterrent how do you deal with this new
phenomenon of a nuclear power basically
using what the newts as a protective
shield to commit genocide
i mean this this is just proof that
vladimir putin has always been playing
the long game for mother russia there
was an agreement in the early 90s
between the uk the americans and the
russians that ukraine gives up their
nuclear arsenal that's a deterrent
in favor that the russians won't ever
invade and he eventually invaded and now
he's got the will plus he's also got the
terminal illness where he wants to go
down as a great premier one of the best
of all time and he's got the finger you
know a guy with dementia possibly two
guys with dementia on their their
fingers on the trigger and and they're
just throwing around the word nuclear
like it doesn't matter and to someone
that old that wants to be you know go
down in history
what's he got to lose maybe he'll do it
it's very very scary what we need to do
is not just meet force with force we
need to meet that deterrent with the
potential of greater force and hopefully
people close enough to vladimir putin i
mean maybe soon when he goes you know
under anesthesia for surgery maybe he
doesn't wake up who knows what they're
going to do because russians are smart i
hope they're smart enough not to want to
destroy the free world because you've
got to figure uh a missile from russia
can be in the uk in under 200 seconds i
don't have the exact exact math but it's
fast
i mean that's that is a terrifying fact
isn't it and you know that he is saber
rattling and the question is is he mad
is he bad is he both and how you know is
he sick we just don't know enough about
putin's state of mind to know whether
actually it's in his calculus to
potentially launch a missile we just
don't know do we i think it's all three
of those things with you know and his
backs against the wall he was supposed
to roll through there have kiev and put
put a puppet government up you know like
he did in belarus when when you know
someone won a corrupt election if you
can imagine that happening in the world
and and uh that's what was going to
happen they're going to keep the
ukrainian flag up russia has that china
rolls into taiwan it's all part of the
big plan but fortunately and you know i
don't i don't i don't think that uh um
zielinski's the you know the
greatest hero that he portrays but he
was able to raise morale and it's
ukrainian people that are fighting back
obviously with some backing from us but
they're really showing what it's like to
love your country and to fight for it
that's the only good thing if you can
call it a good thing
of this whole conflict or war is that
ukrainians are showing that you can
stand up against tyranny and you can
defeat it which i think they're doing
well he's certainly raising their morale
and the people are fighting for him and
i think they seem as an inspiring leader
and you know i remember as we as the
anniversary of what you did all those
years ago i remember being in new york i
flew into new york that night and i
remember just the unbelievable
excitement that was in the air when news
broke that osama bin laden was dead and
then i had the great honor of meeting
you and shaking the hand of the man that
did it and i just want to thank you
again for what you did because that was
an extraordinary thing and we're all uh
massively in your debt so great to talk
to you rob
always at any time pierce great to talk
to you guys
and says the next the wife of tennis
legend boris becker speaks out for the
first time after his shock prison
sentence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well tennis legend boris becker is
beginning two and a half years behind
bars for hiding millions of assets to
avoid paying off debts i spoke to his
wife lily in her first exclusive
interview since his shock sentence
stick around for the end she revealed a
little bit more than i was expecting
it's hard because it's public it's
everywhere it's hard because everybody
has an opinion about it rightly so
um and i'm here to to actually show
everybody that he has a bunch of really
strong women behind him and here to not
speak be for for him but to protect him
i mean i mean
it was well known that uh a while ago
you and his girlfriend lillian had a bit
of a spat you went on social media and
had a bit of a popular but has what's
happened brought you guys close in a
weird way that you both see a guy that
you've had great love for go to prison
absolutely and up until today i'm super
embarrassed and i'm we're going to meet
her pretty soon and i would love to
apologize to her face-to-face
to lillian absolutely she was the first
one to uh reach out to me i asked how i
was doing how i was holding up house
armor days absolutely i said thank you
um we're doing okay a okay as good as it
can be
then i've called barbara the ex-wife and
um it was just a non-spoken thing it's
like right here we are let's get
together and let's protect this guy the
humiliation was already enough for him
to have it done
on air for three weeks long
sitting there not being able to to
well he can't defend himself but as if
you know burris you know in order he has
pride
and uh to then be sentenced and
everybody immediately having something
to say yeah he deserves it
we don't know what he deserves but
humiliate your
humiliation that's his opinion when you
heard he was getting a two and a half
year prison center that's a long time
and this is the man who's the father of
yours your son amadeus he's 12 now what
was that moment like for you when you
heard the sentence i completely broke
down i couldn't hear i couldn't believe
what i was hearing because i was
convinced up until the judge made her
verdict that he was gonna get off a
little bit lighter than i mean two and a
half years and i had to keep it together
and i did not know how i did it
i i kind of did it thank god my son i
was prepared i kept him out of school he
was upstairs does he know what's
happened
i i he does now he did i had to break it
down to him his kids will tell him at
school he'll see it on the internet
right but there was the thing i had kept
we as a family including boris millian
and the kids we had
by
uh purposely not allowed him or spoke
about to trial or anything and then um
and i didn't have no chance but to break
my heart or actually his heart last
sunday and it's i don't wish this up on
anybody it was the hardest thing i had
to do with the 12 year old to tell him
his dad was going to prison he did he
just couldn't grasp him still can't and
it breaks my heart but it just made me
into tiger mama because i feel now that
i think we've all been through enough as
a family
there is a mother involved i'm not here
i'm not asking for sympathy i don't want
it nor would boris want that i'm asking
for empathy i'm asking for everybody
that had an opinion or wanted to write
about him
to please stop you saw boris um just
before he got sentenced
what was his state of mind about this
does he feel the judge did criticize him
for not showing any humility or
accepting he done much wrong do you
think as the time came nearer that boris
understood what he'd done and it was
wrong i think boys always knew what was
what was going to happen he knew from
the beginning this is going to be a
tough one it's going to be worldwide but
what do you do in a situation like that
you just go and be mentally prepared and
thank god
his mental health is so strong and he
was probably prepared for these moments
because life at boris is never boring it
is a headline of the headline and what
has happened to him now i think uh
please allow him to heal behind closed
doors and that do you know how he's
getting on in prison it must be a very
different experience liliana has told me
that he's okay he's fine i mean it's not
a five-star hotel is it like he can be
as good as he can be and what about his
sense of
pride you talked about earlier does he
feel a sense of shame about what's
happened wouldn't you i think everybody
is and that's why i feel that you know
he's embarrassed you know he's
humiliated he knows that everybody
always has so how is he going to pick
himself up from this
and
the best way he can stay trying to stay
mentally strong focused because it's
just an obstacle in the vote it takes a
pretty extraordinary guy
he is extraordinary well i was going to
say i mean i know boris socially and
i've always liked him he's a he's a
great character and he was a wonderful
sportsman i remember when he won women
he was one of the best i mean amazing
he's also always had a magnetic appeal
to women
and here you are a beautiful woman
talking as his ex-wife very lovingly
about him lily and his girlfriend very
beautiful talks lovingly about him his
first ex-wife talks loving me about him
you're all coming together
what is it about boris becky that has
that draw to women like you well that's
exactly it it's either you have it or
you don't he has a great charisma he is
a fantastic father a funny guy honest
and you either have that swag or not and
he is
if you've met him you know how
charismatic he is you know when you sit
down and he tells a story you are just
glued to him he's got this blue eyes and
it's just a charm and this is how he's
won lots of fans so how will he deal now
lily do you think with the fact he's now
a convicted criminal because he is a man
of pride and when he comes out of prison
it may be in a year a year and a half
whatever it may be he will come out as a
convicted criminal his life will never
be the same again says who
well he is a convicted he's a convicted
criminal who says his love will never be
the same again for if the people that
are standing by him and which is a lot i
think don't we all of a comeback kid he
did yes and i'm going to get
he has
well he's been committed for a crime
well you're doing the time for those who
don't those who haven't followed it he
was sentenced to two and a half years
for hiding 3.1 million dollars in assets
to avoid paying debt so he got into
heavy debt and he tried to hide money
which should have been used to pay it
off that was his crime do you think that
the sentence was justified no i think
it's way too harsh absolutely i think
it's way too hot should it be a
punishment absolutely
um i think personally obviously i'm
biased i'm i'm you know part of the
baccalaureate name is becca but i think
two and a half in in in
it's heart it's very harsh um but we
knew from the beginning that this this
judge he was not gonna take no uh are
you hoping to take amadeus to see his
father he is dying to see his father i
have just be
i have just told a 12 year old um that
his father is in jail and the saddest
part about it was that i couldn't break
it down because these kids are now going
on youtube they are going on the
internet internet is crew
but he also has a
loving support system around him and um
he's curious
um and i've told him we all make
mistakes you pop i didn't listen to the
law and he's on the naughty step a
bigger one and was the last thing you
said to boris before when he when he
last saw you i honestly i bought him and
um
i said to him
um see you next weekend if you want if
you want to see a uh or be good
he'd gave me this and i sent him a heart
and that was it and you haven't spoken
to him since he went inside no
do you have to go in yourself
uh if if he would want to yes i mean
absolutely
with my son 100 i think i need to be
holding my hands with him and of course
i'm seeing him i'm dying to see him
you're still his wife you're not
divorcing very much still his estranged
wife as that may be but we're still very
much married they've been since we
went our separate ways do you want to
get divorced
um
why did you ask me that i think it's
said you're the most intense lover he's
ever had in his life uh it was from the
beginning intense it was in a complete
true love story there is no introduction
about it and everybody that knows us
knows this you don't want to divorce him
do you
um that's a why do you do this it's not
that i don't want to get a divorce i
think we should handle our business at
the right time this is not the right
time this is everybody's involved we
will do it however right now you're
still his wife and you still love him of
course i do
of course i do we all love him lillian
loves him barbara loves him amadeus
loves him but right now we need to be a
unity and i think this this let's get
divorced or not that's definitely on the
back burner let's get him started let's
get him right then we all get to as we
do right now and then we do it when it's
the right time okay well i wanted to
keep you here to set the record straight
so there we have it a world exclusive
boris barrack is not divorced from lily
they're still married uh he's
talked about your crazy love i can see a
bit of crazy love coming back from you
to him so who the hell knows how this
all washes up but it's it's fascinating
and thank you for staying and clarifying
that yeah of course i think that's
important too
uncensored next is kim kardashian
destroying marilyn monroe's legacy by
desecrating her dress two of the world's
most famous marine impersonators will
debate
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
fans of marilyn monroe have slammed kim
kardashian for wearing her iconic happy
birthday mr president dress at the met
gala red carpet in new york so fashion
or fast who better to debate this than
two star marilyn impersonators heather
chaney performs in las vegas city
kennedy here in the uk and trust me hang
around for the song at the end
marilyn's lost everything she lost her
childhood she lost her loves she lost
her life that one dress that iconic
moment was so marilyn and it's been now
stolen and i remember kim kardashian's
dad was part of the o.j simpson team
that said if the glove don't fit you
must have quit well kim the dress didn't
fit so quick
i mean look heather i gotta say i'm with
susie on this because when i see her
trying to bust her way into that dress
she clearly doesn't fit it and that's
despite we're going to play a clip now
of kim kardashian talking about trying
on the dress and realizing it doesn't
even fit let's listen to this
so they came with like armed guards and
gloves and
i tried it on it didn't fit me and so i
looked at them and i said give me like
three weeks and i i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to to be able to fit this but
i it was such a challenge it was like a
roll right i was determined yeah i was
determined to win it
sorry what does she mean a role she's
not an actress
marilyn monroe was a goddess of the
silver screen kim kardashian is a
reality tv star a role was she talking
about heather
i listen
in in real marilyn was actually sewn
into the dress so i find it
um not surprising that they had to do it
for kim k and i myself i have no idea
how she got the back end of her in the
dress well she didn't she didn't hit her
that's the point she couldn't get her
back into the dress so they left it open
and then covered it up apparently
yes
apparently i haven't seen all the
footage as of yet um it's very unsightly
and in my view very demeaning to the
legacy and memory of marilyn monroe
that's my point
exactly
but i come from a place of like
working in a theme park i've seen
people roaming through over and over
with images of maryland that are
frankly far worse with like the skull
face i mean the images of maryland have
been tarnished for years and this is
just this is a little different because
it's bigger in the spotlight because
it's the infamous happy birthday dress
but somebody you know tarnishing the
image of marriages okay not a first for
that i don't really agree but uh susie
final word to you quickly
it's just ridiculous and the sad thing
is now is that marilyn monroe
had a moment in history and kim
kardashian has clung on to that and
she's you're right pierre she's not an
actress she's a reality star and i think
it's a very sad day for that dress it's
tarnish now and it's it's been hijacked
like a mark chapman hijacked john lennon
and i'm here in liverpool and that dress
was marilyn's and it'll ever be the
marilyn kim kardashian dress and that's
a really sad day for what you know kim
had her own thing do your own thing i'm
an impersonator i don't have to do my
own thing that's what i do kim was
different she could have made her
moments okay steal it i agree with you
can i leave though with the pair of you
just saying happy birthday mr president
to me in maryland boys
happy birthday
mr morgan
happy birthday
to you heather
oh you want me to go yeah
happy
birthday
he's loving this today
to you
[Music]
happy
birthday
to you
happy birthday
little pears
happy birthday
to you
fabulous now that is the spirit of
marilyn monroe thank you ladies
now who better to unearth the secrets of
the most private family on earth than
one of the most connected women in the
world she's edited tatler vanity fair
and the new yorker author of the new
explosive book the palace papers inside
the house of windsor it's tell all titan
tina brown
megan simply
didn't realize didn't understand how
different the monarchy is from the
inside to what it looks like from the
outside from the outside it's palaces
it's global tours it's being you know
adored it's being one of the most famous
people in the world from inside you know
it can be really dull it is grunt work
but she gave it 18 months i mean i just
i just can't buy this i think she's
genuinely planned the whole thing i
think she thought i'll come in hoover up
this prince yank him back to california
and become the new angelina and brad
pitt i think she thought honestly that
she could
play a different kind of of princess
that she could actually i don't think
she went in there thinking i'm going to
snatch harry out of there i think she
thought she was going to be
able to be this global humanitarian
princess the problem was
that harry was actually by that time
sixth in line to the throne
he's not although he's a global
superstar inside the palace hierarchy
he's not really such a big deal i mean i
don't really have a police they want to
go and live in california and lead the
life of well
everyone should be allowed to lead the
lies they want to leave no one can force
them to do what they do my central
problem with the situation now is that
they want to keep their royal titles
which make them all the money from
netflix spotify and so on they don't
want to do any of the duty that comes
with the titles and they want to go on
national television quite regularly and
trash the institution of the monarchy
and the royal families a bunch of callus
races which causes incalculable damage i
mean you see in the commonwealth now
when they're going on these tours and
getting some adverse reactions a lot of
that comes back to meghan markle the
first non-white member of the royal
family calling them a bunch of racists
not saying here was well i mean i think
that actually that harry is on a pretty
good mojo right now i mean because he
started doing do you think so he looks
like i do he looks like everybody
well you know i did think that actually
for a while but i do think just recently
he's got his mojo back i think that
invictus that he invented
was a brilliance
i mean this is his legacy and actually
for harry that should be his complete
focus and brown but he doesn't talk to
his brother william right
that's pretty clear in the book very
unhappy situation between him and his
brother and actually i think it's
weakening for william as much as it is
for harry not to have that fraternal
bond they were a great team
it feels like we've lost this guy he
doesn't look that happy to me someone
who else is not remotely happy will be
prince andrew and many will say well he
shouldn't be the queen i thought was
remarkable at phillips memorial service
that she wanted andrew to walk down the
aisle with him it was a really big
statement by the queen i mean i thought
misguided but actually other people
thought it says son and it was his
father he was honoring what did you
think well i mean what is so fascinating
about the queen is where he's always
been able to compartmentalize sovereign
hrh you know the queen
from
mother grandmother and a private world
and actually one of the things that i
learned during this piece is that in the
family they all know who they're going
to see are they going to see the
sovereign because they're going to talk
about matters of you know matters of
import to them it mummy or is it mummy
and granny now like any big ceo like
logan roy's family yeah i mean they like
to snip through sometimes i mean he
thinks he's dysfunctional logan roy can
you see the royals right exactly but
actually it all works just the same as
succession i mean i mean there's some
fantastic descriptions of public figures
in your book tina who's this who you
described as an editorial swashbuckler
an 800 pound gorilla of british tv and
the young lord of misrule who reveled in
transgression
any clues stand up piers morgan it is
you it is you i mean listen you were the
great you were the great sort of prince
of the 90s pierce i mean listen to the
word listen to the 90s i mean the prince
i mean you were unbelievable and
actually i still believe that your
diaries
are
absolutely amazing classic and i want to
see them you know on ice and and singing
and dancing
maybe you know i think
there's they are a portrait of an age
the 90s which are unbelievable one of
the most amazing stories you tell in
that diary is how when princess diana
brought prince william no you went to
lunch at kensington yeah with william
diana prince
i mean think about it can you two hours
of everything two hours and what struck
me william was 13 and she told him
everything everything absolutely
everything well that was what's so
incredible i mean can you imagine today
i hope it might happen but i i suspect
it won't that the duchess of cambridge
would invite you and your peers over to
london
if you're watching uh your role of
highness i am available i think they're
actually sending their kids to one of
the schools that my my kids went to uh
yeah but it was an ask me anything lunch
right now you asked her anything you
wanted you spend a lot of time in
america uh and as i as do i prince
charles is trying to woo his american
fans this has happened to yesterday in
fact he went to a school in south london
and was shown how to throw an american
football
so before we show it look at tom brady
throwing what was that
sometimes i could protect it
now let's cut to prince charles
actually not bad i mean i just thought
that was good
given his age and lack of experience uh
you know who could have done that
brilliantly is prince harry because i
was actually told which is very
interesting that prince harry the reason
that he was such a great soldier such a
great shot he has perfect hand-eye
coordination yeah he's brilliant at
throwing balls out he said well let's
send on a happy note with prince harry
uh tina brown the palace plays it's a
riveting read honestly i love the diner
book i love this one i could i'm gonna
read it thoroughly gorge on it not least
about myself uh good luck with the book
and lovely to see you thank you pierce
good luck with this show thank you great
to have you here in the studio
on censored next the most ruthless boss
on tv and he doesn't mince his words in
real life either brian cox coming up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now i've had my fair share of audiences
with terrifyingly powerful media moguls
but to confess the knowledge i've been
sitting across the desk from logan roy
said even my pulse racing here's my
boardroom encounter with the emmy
award-winning star of hbo succession
brian cox
brian great to see you nice to meet you
stop the succession
i've seen that you said that you kind of
thought it was going to be a big hit
because you could feel the quality yeah
of the script but when it went as big as
it did have you ever experienced
anything quite like that in your career
uh
the
debut of the last season
and at the royal festival hall
i walked on
being the eldest member i walk home
first
and the audience reaction was
astonishing
and i actually thought somebody had come
on behind me like some kind of you know
like some iggy pop or something like
that or mick jagger had walked on behind
me and i turned out there was nobody
there and i thought this is weird
do you get a lot of people coming up
simply wanting them to you just wear it
absolutely all the time all the time and
of course it's the easiest thing to say
do you do it of course
of course i mean
you know i love it
[Laughter]
the
the great thing i think about you brian
is you said recently you've reached the
age of mid 70s and you don't care
anymore about saying what you think
about things and you talked about how
when you were younger you would tempo
your words your opinions and stuff but
now you don't care we're in a very odd
place in society i think with this kind
of cancer culture mentality people
walking around on eggshells terrified of
expressing opinions because they're
getting fired they're losing jobs
they're getting shamed and abused and
vilified and so on what do you make of
where society is going what do we do
about it well it's a kind of modern day
mccarthyism
really
uh
it's a kind of raid on people's
sensibilities in order to kind of reduce
them
and make them
i don't know there's there's so much
hypocrisy involved yes that the whole
thing i mean i find the whole thing
completely hypocritical who is the one
you know there's a i mean i'm not
religious but there is a thing in the
the bible when it says lets him without
sin or he she without sin cast the first
stone and there seems to be a lot of
casting of stones and it's like a virus
you know elon musk calls it a woke
virus and it feels to me like what's
ironic to me is the people doing it they
claim to be liberals there's nothing
liberal about it no there's nothing it's
the opposite it's almost a form of
fascism it is total fascist
you're absolutely right it is total
fascism and people are behaving more and
more and and and
in the kind of hypocritical you see it's
hypocrisy again the hypocritical notion
of i'm being liberal but actually you
are being fascist yes and people should
just stop it and behave themselves i
completely agree and it's and again the
ironys fascism would be the one thing
they would all say is the thing they
hate most exactly and they're trying to
counter but in fact they're practicing
it themselves exactly and you're
absolutely right on that i just i i find
it appalling and i really do when you
see what happened to someone like jk
rowling you you spoke about i think one
of your kids brought you up to speed on
what she'd say and it was you know women
menstruate for example and you were like
what i don't understand what all the
fuss is about and yet she was exposed to
death threats and all sorts of attempts
to cancel her and so on
again i just felt everyone's losing
their minds well i i couldn't understand
that whole thing at all you know man i
thought well listen this is not an area
i am not necessarily permitted to tread
upon but at the same time i thought it
was a kind there was something
deeply unjust about it you know i just
felt that and uh you know and it's
happening time and time again
and it's not only it's not only the
people who are counseled it's also the
people like their families like their
children like their parents like that
you know it has it has such
ramifications it's sort of it creates a
sort of like an earthquake situation
yeah
on jk rowling she was she said standing
up for women's rights we've got to a
strange place again where politicians
supreme court nominees
are struggling to say what a woman is
that they're too scared to say it's an
adult female yeah but the fear of the
mob but we we've never examined you see
the point is we're beginning to examine
things that we have never hitherto
examined before particularly the re the
relationship between men and women and
particularly the sexual relationship
between men and women and how that
relationship is operated and it
particularly affects
young men and women because they don't
know how or what or how or should they
express themselves in certain ways and
there's a kind of form of fascism
because of knock down effect where they
they you know i i you know there are
kids who just do not know how to
approach one another now and it's all
the two they're so scared
yeah it's too scary but it's also we're
a lot to blame because we haven't
attended to it we haven't actually had
schools of study about how those what
those relationships when you talk about
study i mean i'm i'm incredibly
depressed by what's going on at
university
and colleges and campuses around the
world where you see new york posted a
piece of about five professors who all
got cancelled and it's happening all
over the place so one of them was
actually giving a lecture given for 20
years where he talked about the usage of
offensive language and to illustrate
this in the lecture he said some
offensive language and he got cancelled
because people didn't have the brain
power to understand what he was doing
well this is part of the virus and
and it kind of
i don't know it just makes people behave
in the most
idiotic insensitive and again as i say
hypocritical way you know they feel one
thing but they practice something quite
else what's the answer to it
i don't know i mean i do i i it's a
we're not a very sad place at the moment
really i think with what's going on both
in ukraine and what's been going on in
america especially in the last
seven years you know i mean it's just
been a very bad time and we're so
confused we just don't know what to
believe anymore because all our belief
systems are falling apart and so we're
we're like vigilantes we have vigilante
belief groups which is what i believe
the whole world culture is yes it's a
form of vigilante it is it is
mccarthyiii it's exactly the same
mentality
rooting people out for in perceived
indiscretions
and then basically evaporating them from
society that's right and and and there's
no we go why is the reason and then of
course it's catching i mean uh
the the it's catching a bit in my
business it catches because suddenly
projects i mean bill murray the other
day and a wonderful i mean he he made it
a mark
and it was taken away
as being offensive
and the picture he was making was
stop stop the whole thing now bill went
on see i think it was cnn and explained
himself i thought rather brilliantly
actually saying you know we le it's
about times of change
i lived and grew up in one time and i'm
meeting another time and it's very hard
to know how to approach that time where
do we go how do we come in where where
is the entryway to make a conversation
and just make even a joke with one
another well anyone anyone can take
offense in anything and they can then
weaponize the offense exactly and that's
where we've got then it's almost
impossible to defend yourself because
the court of public opinion passes
verdict immediately that's right
let's turn to a happier thing okay you
went to lambda where you you attended
land of the great drama school my middle
son went there he's a young actor
and he remembered you going there and
doing a q a speech and he said the most
memorable thing that you said was that
you should always carry a picture of
yourself as a child to remember to
maintain childlike enthusiasm exactly do
you do that yourself i do i i actually i
keep it on my phone hopefully it'll come
up
there it is and it just came out i think
we've got it on that's it that's on your
phone you'll show me it here and we've
got it on screen
when you see that little little boy
have you lived up to every dream that
little boy had
i have to say pretty much i have
actually i mean i i i recognize the look
i reckon that and i'm constantly and the
look is always different on every day
but today is going you know it's not bad
when you've got a mistake did you ever
think you get to this stage of your life
and your career and you would suddenly
be in this monster hit
brilliantly written with amazing actors
all around you and everywhere you're
going they think you're mick jagger i
mean it's pretty amazing right yeah it's
kind of crazy i mean i think you know
i've been in this business now believe
it or not i have now entered the seventh
decade of being in this business amazing
you know and is this the highlight for
you yeah i have no question and it's and
it's sort of moved in that direction i
mean
the map of my life has been really
i think
i mean full of extraordinary tragedy and
heartbreak but really quite remarkable
and and and made me
very respectful and how like logan roy
are you in real life well as a father
as a father i have certain difficulties
i i i because i didn't have a father
and i think that's something logan ryan
have in common and the difference
between logan
we have a we are both disappointed with
the human experiment yeah we're deeply
disappointed with that but i'm an
optimist i believe it will get better he
is
now i've heard reports rumors that you
maybe think you're going vegan is that
right well i'm thinking of of going
plant life i mean i
the problem is i like the taste of
hamburgers
i i actually rather like that well
here's my here's my problem you know
there are some wonderful plant life
hamburgers and i couldn't tell the
difference
here's my problem my problem you talked
about hypocrisy earlier these are percy
pigs are you familiar with these i don't
know so they took them vegetarian
they're now taking them vegan and i've
got to do this to show you what we do
here play this
[Music]
here's my problem they're making these
vegan percy pigs but they're pigs heads
yeah why would any vegan want to be seen
eating a pig's head whilst claiming to
be virtuous about animal welfare let me
give you the the the the scenario i
would say
so he looks at this or she looks at this
and she says ah pig
now a pig is a vegan
a pig is a natural vegan pigs they don't
eat meat they tend to be still eating
the pig's head yes but that's in respect
brian i've got to leave you there what a
pleasure to see you thank you thank you
for fighting the cancelled culture mob
we need more like you out there that's
it for me keep it uncensored good night
biggest issue in britain right now
undoubtedly is cost of living it is
energy and all that goes with that
inflation look you know i don't want the
government to do very much step back
from most of our lives but you know
there's a point when you say actually
these guys are getting a grip somewhere
along the line you want
to believe that the system that is meant
to be running things the chancellor the
prime minister who are going to somehow
step in and make life just a little
easier for the average person
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zoro suleiman the
conservatives are licking their wounds
after yesterday's local elections having
so far lost control of 11 councils
across the uk labour gaining six in the
lib dems five the snp at the biggest
party in scotland while in northern
ireland shin fein have received the most
first preference votes zakir starmer has
said he's confident no rules were broken
at an event last april where he was
pictured drinking beer with colleagues
durham police have opened an
investigation after they received
significant new information
and the queens decided only working
members of the royal family will join
her on the balcony for the platinum
jubilee meaning no harry megan or prince
andrew
well that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you